vous savez la france fin mai les
français globalement ils ont fait 165
milliards d' épargne
pendant cette année sauf que 30% de la
population on désépargner et c'est cette
population là qui a réellement souffert
de la crise de l'aco vite c'est cette
population là que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les enquêtes qu'elle soit faite
par le secours populaire par le secours
catholique ou par les restos du coeur et
je pense que c'est une question qui va à
un moment ou à un autre
pénétrez dans la campagne présidentielle
et il faudra que tous les candidats y
compris le président candidat se
prononce à son sujet
bonsoir jacques maire soit d'être avec
nous on en parle souvent ces fameuses
deux thèses qui s'affrontent donc y
croire une bonne fois pour toutes sur
cette question de la pauvreté en france
l'insee ou de secours catholique mais je
pense que les deux ont raison mais parce
qu'il ne parle pas de la même chose
alors oui effectivement quand le
gouvernement dit le quoi qu'il en coûte
à protéger une grande partie des
français où il a incontestablement
réseau oui et on peut le voir d'ailleurs
en particulier sur toute une série de
deux salariés mais quand le secours
catholique dit ceux qui n'ont pas été
protégé par justement cette espèce de
parapluies du quoi qu'il en coûte ont vu
leur situation se dégrader durant
l'année du coc vide et se dégrader
encore actuellement il a aussi
incontestablement raison alors on
commence avec les chiffres de l'insee
pour aller bien dans le détail que
distille alors ils disent que les gens
qui se situe à 60 % du seuil de pauvreté
il faut d'abord expliquer que ce qu'on
appelle 60 % du seuil de pauvreté c'est
un revenu net qui soit égal à 60% du
revenu médian pas du revenu moyen
autrement dit ces 11 100 euros par mois
et bien ce chiffre est aujourd'hui à peu
près stable il avait monté en 2018 un
petit peu redescendue mais disons il est
resté stable en
2010 8 et 2 19 bon donc ça c'est une
c'est une première chose après
évidemment se pose la question de savoir
est ce que ce chiffre est réellement
pertinent mais ça c'est un autre
problème et ces pauvres jacky sont ils
alors les pauvres qui sont concernés
justement parle le rapport qu'a fait le
secours catholique il faut voir que
c'est plusieurs choses d'abord il faut
dire leur nombre le secours catholique
estime qui le reçoit aujourd'hui 7
millions je dis bien 7 millions de
demandes de soi disant de l'aide
alimentaire si on reprend le chiffre de
l'insee il ya quand même quelque chose
qui est intéressant il faut voir que et
on le voit sur le sur le graphique il
faut voir que le suivant les catégories
c'est très différent alors 40 % des
chômeurs à peu près sont dans cette
catégorie mais il ya aussi des 7 % des
patrons de pme et ça cette fois des
indépendants et ça c'est important parce
que quand j'ai dit que la moyenne
nationale c'était à 14,6 pour cent mais
on voit que c'est plus important donc ça
prouve qu'il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle
les actifs pauvres si vous voulez les
gens qui sont actifs qui ont un emploi
mais qui sont pour et alors dernier
point qui est très important c'est
effectivement la part des enfants on se
rend compte que 1 enfant sur cinq en
france 20% des enfants sont dans des
familles qui sont considérés comme
pauvres et que dit le secours catholique
maintenant alors justement le secours
catholique insiste beaucoup sur le fait
qu' aujourd'hui alors ils aident à peu
près 7 à 8 millions de personnes il
insiste sur le fait que le revenu médian
des gens qu il n a baissé et se situe
aujourd'hui à un niveau très faible 540
euros contre 740 euros ce qui serait à
peu près la moyenne pour les gens qui
sont considérés comme très pauvre donc
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point est bien c'est que le nombre de
gens qui ont recours à l'aide
alimentaire a énormément augmenté et il
a continué d'augmenter l'année de l'aco
vite c'est pratiquement 7 millions deux
personnes troisième chose qui est aussi
extrêmement inquiétante c'est le fait
que un peu plus du quart de ces
personnes 1 27% et bien sont dans ce
qu'on appelle une grande insécurité
alimentaire alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire vous avez dire que
plusieurs fois par mois ils passent une
journée sans manger autrement dit on est
là en face de gens qui ont faim c'est
pas simplement qu'ils peuvent mal se
nourrir qu'ils ont besoin d aide que ce
soit les restos du coeur ou le secours
catholique pour améliorer le repas non
ils ont faim et 27% c'est quand même un
chiffre très important et le dernier
point sur lequel insiste le secours
catholique c'est le fait que dans les
gens qui viennent avoir accès si vous
voulez à son aide alimentaire il y a des
gens qui ont un salaire et qu'ils sont
au dessus du seuil de pauvreté pas
beaucoup mais ils sont un petit peu au
dessus du seuil de pauvreté sauf que ce
sont des gens qui ont de très grosses
dépenses contraintes alors que ce soit
le loyer ça peut être aussi
l'endettement 1 qui joue le dessus et
donc ils n'ont plus assez d'argent pour
se nourrir donc il y à bien un problème
assez majeur de pauvreté même de grande
pauvreté en france on a beaucoup parlé
des étudiants justement dans cette crise
que dit le secours catholique alors le
secours catholique est aussi très
impressionné par le fait que les
demandes aide alimentaire ont été très
forte chez les jeunes dont les étudiants
évidemment plus 6% dans l'année 2020 et
on comprend tout à fait pourquoi parce
que c'était des jeunes qui faisait très
souvent ce qu'on appelle un petit boulot
alors ce petit boulot ce thème pourrait
être coursier vous ai travaillé dans des
restaurants dans des bars etc tout ça ça
ferling si vous voulez tout le secteur
de l'événementiel qui était un grand
pourvoyeur justement de ces petits bouts
eh bien ça à fermer et même s'ils ont
une petite bourde bien ils se sont
retrouvés avec quasiment rien et or je
dirais du filet de sécurité déployés par
l'état est ce à dire alors que le quoi
qu'il en coûte n'a pas marché dans ce
cas là si vous voulez c'est toujours la
même chose ou will quoiqu'il en compte a
marché pour les gens qui ont été
protégés sauf qu'il faut quand même à
rajouter là une chose le quoi qu'il en
coûte le le système en fait de chômage
partiel qui a été mis en place dans le
cadre de quoi qu'il en coûte
indemniser 84 % du montant du salaire
alors bon très bien quand vous avez un
salaire supérieur à 2000 euros nets dans
84% ça représente une perte mais c'est
pas grave quand vous êtes au smic et
quand justement
vous allez finir le mois ric rac voire
légèrement à découvert est bien perdre
16 % par rapport à un smic ça peut être
tout à fait dramatique ajoutons une
chose à cela le fait que même si vous
n'êtes pas touchés par ce genre de
problème vous pouvez avoir des charges
qui viennent s'ajouter à cela et le fait
que les cantines scolaires n'ont pas
fonctionné pendant une partie c'était
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles le
gouvernement a tenu
au soul à la rentrée 2020 que les écoles
restent ouverts le plus longtemps
possible parce que qu'est ce qui s'était
passé lors du premier confinement les
cantines scolaires ont été fermés et
donc
cette nourriture des enfants qui étaient
payés par là que par la collectivité que
ce soit par l'état par les collectivités
régionales et c est bien elle est
revenue à la charge de famille qui
voyaient déjà leurs revenus se réduire
donc on comprend d'une certaine manière
quels sont les mécanismes de
l'appauvrissement des gens avec l'aco
vide est ce que on peut dire sur cette
question finalement que la pauvreté est
de retour malheureusement oui
malheureusement oui et on voit bien
prenons par exemple ce qui se passe vous
venez juste d'en parler ce qui se passe
dans les antilles à la guadeloupe en
martinique ce sont des régions où nous
avons plus de 30% de la population qui
est sous le seuil de la pauvreté donc on
voit bien qu'il ya des régions où c'est
extrêmement grave et puis globalement
oui c'est un problème qui aujourd'hui se
pose on voit si on recense toutes les
données qui sont fournis par les
différentes ong que ce soit le secours
populaire que ce soit le secours
catholique que ce soit aussi d'ailleurs
les restaurants du coeur qui fournissent
les données de ce coin dulac et bien on
voit qu'il y à une montée de
l'appauvrissement alors il ya une partie
de la population qui s'est assez bien
sorti de la crise de l'aco vide vous
savez la france fin mai les français
globalement ils ont fait 165 milliards
d' épargne
pendant cette année sauf que 30% de la
population on désépargner et c'est cette
population là qui a réellement souffert
de la crise de la queue vite c'est cette
population là que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les enquêtes qu'elle soit faite
par le secours populaire par le secours
catholique ou par les restos du coeur et
je pense que c'est une question qui va à
un moment ou à un autre
pénétrez dans la campagne présidentielle
et il faudra que tous les candidats y
compris le président candidat se
prononce à son sujet merci beaucoup et
on verra si ce sera le cas merci
beaucoup j'accepte fier d'avoir été avec
nous et je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine merci